Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast,
Dan.
Huh?
Ah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
How are you?
How's your week going?
Are you having a rough one?
Will.
It's okay.
It's almost over stars day.
You know,
don't you hate your boss?
A little less on Thursday.
Eight comes in.
Hey,
go over there and do what I say.
And you're like,
oh,
chubby cheeks.
You know.
Gee,
you love to say that to him.
Just grab his muffin top doll.
Watch Vito dose job doing.
Can you technically get fired for that?
He,
Oh,
you have to do is just when you're going in for the disciplinary meeting,
he just,
you know,
you just stay in the pocket.
Just be luck.
I have no problem doing what this man says,
but I can't fight the fact that,
yeah,
I think he's adorable.
We look at them once.
You want to go up there and give him a little,
you know,
oh well we'll put on a chai day.
Yeah,
that's a fucking great way to get your ass fired.
I don't know.
What if everybody does it though.
You know the strength in numbers.
Is this like a Sally field movie?
Should I be fucking standing up holding a sign?
You know,
union,
right?
So brave.
It was so brave what she did in the mines.
MMM.
Is there any word more overused in the entertainment,
specifically the movie acting business then brave.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ.
As any actor ever looked up that fucking word.
The way you went out there with that band,
Dan,
it was such a brave performance.
Not Jesus Christ.
You know,
just cook.
When she'd go over to craft service and get yourself something that has yogurt
in it,
you're fucking stupid.
You know,
courageous,
brave,
important.
This was a story that needed to be told.
Oh my God,
those fucking award shows.
And it never dawns on him the irony that everything we're wearing colluding with
the sweatpants and t shirt I have on right now is all made in a sweatshop by
some crying child and fucking three in the morning and check in and wherever
Honduras assumption right.
And they're all up there acting like they give a fuck about people.
It's like you dealt,
you want to go when there you want fucking Ruth buzzy or whatever fucking name
is to say what you're wearing.
Looks good.
You know,
and then you want to win the shiny thing and you want to cry and thank your
mother and pretend you're down to earth and go back to your fucking infinity
pool.
That's what you really want to do.
Right.
Do a little fucking,
you know,
you have Jack Nicholson come over and do some blow off your titties.
You know,
if you're a guy,
uh,
you,
who,
who knows what you want to do out here.
Yeah.
I ain't know what I'm talking about.
You know,
I'm just having one of those scatterbrain days and I went to bed early last
night,
you know,
as I always do,
whenever I go on tour with Versie and Bart,
nick,
I think all of us like for the next three days have to like dry out and try to
get about,
oh,
about 14 hours sleep.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm,
I'm off the booze.
I'm off to cigars.
You know,
the usual fucking thing.
I'm all over the goddamn place.
And um,
oh fuck.
You know what?
Somebody told me yesterday,
here's a new thing.
All right,
how fucking in this fucking world that just keeps getting more and more creepy.
You know,
that whole big brother thing,
but blah,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then people are saying,
oh,
big brother turns out it's actually us.
Um,
and it is,
it is because we're just keep going along with this shit.
Yeah.
Liz is built,
just tell the fucking story before you go on your stupid little rant here.
Alright.
So Buddy might tells me the other day,
right?
He,
uh,
that a friend of his came over to do some work on his house because,
if you own a house,
you're constantly trying to fix it so it doesn't fall down.
That's what they don't tell you.
You know,
when they show the commercial and the real estate commercials,
you know,
a white picket fence,
golden retriever,
your wife had six kids and she's still hot,
right?
There's not,
the other song goes anyways,
and they're all running around there.
They're,
uh,
you know,
ridiculously green,
front yard played Frisbee,
you know,
the dog's not trying to eat anybody.
The wife's laughing.
The kids are all good looking right,
everything's fine,
right?
Nobody has a list.
Nobody has,
you know,
fucking jealousy issues.
You know,
guy doesn't have dad bod.
He's basically crushing it.
They can and you just look at it and you're like,
you know what,
if I,
if I know if I buy a house,
you know,
I know I'm not going to look like that,
but is that the mood I'm going to be in?
It's like a drug,
right?
So anyways,
he fucking um,
he fucking has his guys buddy come over and do some work.
So he goes to pay him and is it all good guys do are you don't need to pay him.
You don't even pay me.
And he's like,
no,
come on,
I want to pay it.
Nah,
tell you I'm not going to accept it.
Just take the fucking money.
Right.
They had to do a sketch like that with too polite friends and it ends up in a
knife fight and one person finally kills the guy.
And then fucking stuffs the money in his mouth.
Should they do a sketch like that?
I think they should.
Um,
anyways,
so he goes for finally the guy goes,
you don't have to pay me,
just get me a case of beer.
So the guy goes fine.
So the closest place that add a little bit,
oh,
was cvs.
So it goes down to cvs.
Okay.
He buys the fuck in case of beer and the lady behind the lady behind the counter
goes,
do you have an id?
And he's looking at her like,
bitch,
I'm 50.
But he goes,
do you really think I,
you know,
you don't think I'm of age?
She goes,
I need to swipe your license.
And she,
he goes for what?
She goes,
oh um,
basically for health insurance purposes they record,
you know,
if you drink or not and if you drink,
your premium goes up because you're a drinker.
Now what the fuck this cds give a shit about rat and everybody out who's a
fucking booze face out there,
right?
Cause you know what it is the money that they're going to fucking be able to to
knock up,
you know on your premium to pump it up.
CVS gets,
it gets a little kickback.
So I would fucking works.
It's like when I drive you to fucking amazon.com right?
If you go through my website they get me a little eight.
Thanks for sending some business our way.
Break you off a couple of homies.
Right.
But I'm not costing any more money.
I'm the hero where this,
I don't cost you any more money.
Whether you go directly to Amazon,
if you go to my website,
it doesn't make any difference to me.
And I'm also not ratting you out.
What I'm trying to say here is I am a way better person than cvs.
No,
I'm fucking with you.
Look where I'll try to make money out of here.
But that's,
that's really fun.
It's fucking ridiculous.
I actually,
I was trying to look at it from the insurance company side of it cause you know
God damn well everybody goes in there and lies.
Do you smoke?
No.
You drink.
No,
I mean maybe I'll have a beer,
I don't know,
on the 4th of July to support the troops.
Yeah.
Do you engage in any,
uh,
drug activity?
I mean foods or drugs?
Self,
technically,
yes,
but I mean that others,
Nah,
no,
I would do you have unprotected sex with prostitutes?
Listen,
I got a phone call.
Can I,
can I take this?
You know,
you know,
he knows the deal.
You'll lie your fucking ass off.
You're going to get life insurance.
You lie your fucking ass off.
Right?
So on one side,
I actually have empathy for insurance companies because I understand that aspect
of it.
Provided they ever fucking paid out any God damn money remotely.
Like they said they were gonna you know the deal,
you pay for insurance,
they say you're covered and you say to them,
hey,
if this happens,
am I going to be covered if I,
I got the,
uh,
the old stuff,
the toe insurance.
So if I wake up in the morning,
I stubbed my toe.
Okay,
I'm a man,
I can take it.
But if I break my fucking tail,
okay.
And you know,
my job is to skip on stage every night.
If I have to take a night off,
can you,
can you kick me?
Do you know the fucking $25 feature spot money?
Can you kick that to me?
They're like,
absolutely,
I got high.
So if I break my toe,
stub my toe in my house of cards,
yeah,
absolutely.
You're covered right now what happens?
You start be telling you break it.
If I can call them up,
they're like,
okay,
I gotta go send it through the,
uh,
you're not getting paid quadrant quadrant of the fucking insurance company.
Then they come back and what do they do?
They'll give you like fucking 13 bucks instead of the 25 they owed you nine or
13 between 25 doesn't seem like a lot money,
right?
But you just ratchet that up there.
Right?
But if they owed you two 50,
now I give you one 30.
What they owed you 25 grand and the only gave you fucking six.
That's what the fuck they do.
They're in the business of taking your fucking money and buying themselves a
yacht.
And fucking bang in Victoria secret models in the ass while looking at the next
year's model of fucking,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's what they're in the business of.
They are not in the business of fucking help with people during the business of
taking your money,
telling you that you're going to be covered.
And then when you go,
dude,
what the fuck?
Right?
They go,
yeah,
go fuck yourself cause we got more money.
Take it or leave it.
Right.
And what should happen is like,
you know,
when,
uh,
do you remember the mighty heroes when they would send out that little signal
and then they'd all fucking tour diaper man and strong man,
they'd all turn into something,
what was it?
Batman.
I don't fucking remember what everybody's insured by.
That company should go at those cons to be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
I thought you said this guy was covered.
Okay,
this is what you're doing to him.
You're going to do it to all of us.
Right.
I'm going back to the Sally field thing.
You know what the problem is?
Is nobody likes their neighbor.
You know,
you look across Danum,
you look at the car he's driving,
he looked at his wife either don't understand what he bought or you want it.
There's never a middle ground like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm pretty much on par with this guy and I keep my ego can handle living across
from him.
You either going to resent them or not understand them.
So then when he gets fucked out of money,
he's telling you the story.
You're sitting there nodding your head,
acting like you don't like it.
But yea two minutes is a part of your soul is getting filled up,
isn't it?
Admit it.
You know like your neighbors,
right?
Yeah.
If it really came down to it,
don't you want a house is big as your house and your neighbors when it'd be
great if they just weren't there anymore.
Somehow there was wasn't any like forensics and they could figure it out that
you a hastens his demise and took over his house.
Just added a fucking hallway between your house and his right.
Then the whole other house is yours.
Right?
So when your wife and kids are driving you nuts,
you just say,
listen,
Daddy's going over to his other life.
I'll be back when I can deal with you.
And everybody just looks at you like those,
that family in that real estate commercial just smiling and waving,
being like,
yeah,
it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
All right then do you go in there right and said he's you want,
you've got booze,
you got cigars,
you know you got him a PSU slash your fucking whore.
They ought to have that the timeout room for a married guy.
You know,
and I know what you ladies to take it.
Well,
why don't they have a time out room for women?
Ain't no what I say?
Well,
why don't you come up with it?
The world doesn't owe you around a drinks.
Okay,
now God damn it,
you got debt multitasking.
Bray.
Once you sit down with a couple other prods or be in your room,
you know bunch shit that makes you live longer.
See if you notice what the guy,
everything I said would slowly fucking kill me.
The bows to cigars,
the horse,
all of it just,
it just eats away at your soul and your fucking liver,
right?
Women would go on there.
The first one,
the first things they'd probably want is like the most beautiful fucking tub
they ever could find so they could take a nice fucking bath.
You know what their crazy little fucking soaps,
right?
And have a whole spa day and they'd have a friend that they could sit down and
get all of that resentment out of their heart with someone who can actually
listen to it.
They download all that shit.
He just totally clean up their soul before they go into the next room and get
fucking banged by Brad Pitt.
You know,
whoever the fucking Jake Gyllenhaal guy is now a days.
Who is it?
Is it Justin Bieber?
Has he become a man yet?
He's in his 20s,
right?
He's riding the wave out of teen idol.
Dumb slowly becoming a man might,
as long as he doesn't remake blue lagoon,
I think that kid's going to be all right.
Um,
anyways,
I'm not Jesus Christ is 12 minutes of your life.
You'll never get back,
huh?
Um,
you know what today is about everybody.
Today's not about you.
Today's not about me.
Today's not even about America.
You know what today's about.
Today's about the Boston Bruins versus Detroit Red Wings.
That's what it's all about.
Okay?
It's funny that they play all these fucking games and they can come down to one
God damn game for those of you who don't watch hockey,
all right?
Which is kind of me.
I just pay attention to it because I've,
ah,
you fucking consequence.
Can I pass?
What ever worked the first fucking time?
You know,
they're always like,
you know,
that's not secure enough.
Well,
it's like,
it's so fucking secure.
I can't do it on one time while I'm still in a fucking podcast.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Anyways,
they play all these goddamn came.
Let me get back into the nicest soothing tone that I had earlier.
Um,
they play all these fucking games,
80 goddamn games,
whatever the hell it is.
And you would think that,
you know,
by now everything would be all sorted out,
right?
Let's go to the playoff picture,
the playoff picture.
Here we go.
I didn't need a picture.
I need a brow to playoff bracket.
I can't read that shit.
Bracket.
Challenge the fucking standings.
That's how,
that's how old I am.
I think.
I feel like if I just yell at a website,
I'll do what I want.
Um,
all right,
so the,
so the fucking red wings have 93 points.
Ah,
they got 93.
That's right.
Cause they,
that's right.
Cause they beat the fucking filthy flyers.
All the flyers needed that one.
The flyers needed that one.
If for some reason I root for the Philadelphia Flyers,
I like,
you know what I mean?
I know that they'd been dirty and fought knowledge ship.
You can't tell me it wasn't entertaining.
You know,
Ron Hextall come and flying out of the net because he's pissed that he lost the
Stanley Cup finals.
I've always enjoyed that shit.
Um,
I don't like the fence,
but I,
I really liked the team.
Uh,
but you know,
Philly fans work at,
you're not liking making you not like them.
So they did the job with me.
I don't like him.
Um,
so anyways,
so Detroit beat him.
So as of right now,
Detroit has 93 points.
Philadelphia has 91.
The Bruins have 91,
but for whatever fucking reason,
I guess head to head maybe or we have a game at hand.
I don't know what,
we're still under the fucking bar line.
So basically tonight,
tonight,
the red wings I think could solidify and let's say you have two more get look to
choice Detroit wins tonight.
There they're either in or they have totally fucking,
you know,
they'd have to basically,
yeah,
put me in net to not make the playoffs.
But if the Bruins,
when we would go up two points on the Philadelphia flyers and a,
this is the biggest fucking game.
They're all big games this week,
but this is a full whole benefit.
This is a big one this week.
And uh,
and other Redwings haven't been the greatest in the past few years,
but they've got enough guys left.
Oh,
and by the way,
I want to say a shout out to that fucking Twitter cunt.
That fucking laughed at me when I said,
you know,
Carolina fucking,
I feel like they always get the best of us.
And he was saying like,
oh,
we're the Bruins are six [inaudible] two the last fucking tie.
Well,
you know,
something,
I never forgot that game.
Seven and 2009 when they came back and they fucking beat us.
And just times,
every time there's a big game like that,
you know,
something,
they always beat us.
And what happens?
We played those contacts and what happened?
What happened?
They ended up beating us in a shootout,
but we did get one point,
thank Christ.
Um,
I think you do right?
Don't you get one point?
If I don't,
every time I turn it on,
they fucking change the rule.
Now they're doing three on three in the overtime,
which I liked,
but you know,
it makes me feel like I,
I blacked out for five years.
So anyways,
we got to win that game tonight.
Um,
and I was hoping,
uh,
Detroit would look a little more tired than they did last night,
but they totally looked like they were on their fucking game.
The one thing we got going is it's back to back.
Um,
which usually during the season you'd have a let down,
but there's too much at stake.
So I think this is going to be a tough game.
And,
uh,
um,
I dunno,
my heart says we're going to win,
but I don't know.
We'll see.
It's been tough for us lately.
All right,
let's,
uh,
oh,
and by the way,
the amount of people that hate the fucking Bruins,
I,
it's like for what?
We want one cup in 40 years,
the fuck is your problem.
You know,
I love when all fucking teams sit there and they act like,
you know,
this team's dirty in this team has excuses,
but our team's fucking squeaky clean.
You know,
I see the pieces of shit on my team,
just the way I see him on your team,
you know,
I see your fucking coaches screaming and yelling anytime anybody touches your
players.
And then when your players touch somebody else,
then don't give a fuck.
Everybody does that.
It's called being an immature cont,
you know,
welcome to the party.
Have a seat.
Can I get you a drink?
All right,
score big everybody.
A little little advert to miss Muslim.
Since uh,
you're paying too much for tickets between all the mark ups and last minutes.
Convert convenience charges,
even printed home fees.
They really charge you to print tickets at home.
It's fucking unbelievable.
All those types of charges I'm telling you,
that just ends up,
you know,
that's just somebody standing in a foyer of a house he can afford just raining
money down on prostitutes.
She ever watch American greed.
That's that.
It gradually all adds up to that.
All right,
you end up paying court side prices for nosebleed seats.
scorebig.com is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all live tickets go on sold?
Do you know that?
And did you know that there's a place to get seats at huge savings?
It's called scorebig.com score big works directly with your favorite teams and
artists to get their unsold seats@unpublishedpricesonlyatscorebig.com can you
name a ticket price and be guaranteed to pay below box office up to 60% off.
Here's all you gotta do.
One number one uno.
Ah,
go to score pig dotcom.
And finally event and seats.
You want to dose to like this little bilingual shit for you here.
Huh?
Make an offer with score.
Biggs name,
uh,
a ticket price feature three
Oh Jesus Trois.
And what does it,
we'll note those trace,
get an instant answer and save up to 60% on your tickets.
Now I realize I've never seen a French referee counts somebody up.
Ah,
the poor cat st seasick.
Queet DCE Vinny.
Um,
no surprise fees and free shipping.
Wait,
did I say get an instant answer and save up to 60% of your tickets?
No surprise fees and free shipping.
Just unbeatable prices on great seats.
And when you're in great seats,
you actually enjoy the game or the show all the more next time.
Yeah.
Cause he is your hammer telling everybody you'd be that guy.
How much did you pay?
Next time you go and see any game or show,
go to score big first and see how much you can save.
Go to score big.com right now.
Click on the microphone,
enter the Promo Code Burr and you'll save an extra $20 off your first ticket
price.
That score,
big.com Promo Code burr high score,
big.com Promo code birth.
But you are are,
um,
I mean once I went to a game,
the guy was like,
hey,
how'd you get tickets?
It's like,
oh,
his scalp demand how much you pay.
And I answered him.
He's like,
yeah,
we got these for this.
It's like,
oh yeah.
Does that make you feel better?
You tight?
Fuck,
I couldn't.
Every once in a while it's like,
you know,
just in those moments you're like,
why didn't I just let another adult do that to me?
You know,
then you hate yourself.
Then you're a little surly to your wife and next thing you know,
yeah,
she's not banging you,
uh,
Boll and branch.
You know,
you probably spend more time with your bedsheets than anything else you own.
You really shouldn't skimp on your bedding,
but most people do because great sheets are very expensive.
Thanks to Boll and branch,
that's not the case anymore.
And when you spend the big bucks on sheets with a super high thread count,
you think you're getting the best.
But what you're really getting is marketing Mumbo jumbo.
Oh my God,
dude,
am I really have to read five paragraphs about sheets?
Thread counts,
have nothing to do with quality and don't get me started on so called Egyptian
cotton.
The fuck is that.
That just came,
just just the name of a plant grown in Pakistan,
in China.
Uh,
well,
you know,
didn't back in the day.
Then they'll know white man bring his ships over there for all the fucking
spices and sheets.
Isn't that what happened?
Um,
you value,
you value your sleep.
They'll put words in my mouth,
but you know what?
You're writing instinctive son of a bitch.
But whenever you head to a department store,
you're forced to pay a huge markup for sheets that aren't even that great.
Boll and branch sheets are different.
First of all,
let me cross my legs during this part.
sit down and let me tell you a story.
You can only get them@andbranch.com so you know you're paying for quality sheets
and not for overhead.
And quite frankly,
they're the most comfortable sheets in the world they made with the entirely
organic cotton and a nights sleeping on bowling and branch sheets.
Makes your day so much better.
Three US presidents sleep on Boll and branch.
Well how do you know that?
Isn't there like a security issue?
Jesus.
How filthy or Bill Clinton's
fucking animal.
Uh,
these are people who can afford to sleep on any brand of sheets in the world and
they even choose bold and they even choose boll and branch.
How can they afford to sleep on any brand in the world?
They only make 400 grand a year before taxes.
Oh,
that's right.
Cause then they give speeches for fucking 500 grand a night to everybody who put
him in office.
So they wash their bribe money.
Oh,
shut up bill.
Okay,
here we go.
They even cut out all the middlemen,
department store markups,
which by the way are up to 800% so you're getting amazing luxurious sheets for a
couple of hundred bucks.
Boland branches.
So Confident,
oh,
this is all capital letters.
Boland bridge is so confident you'll love their sheets.
So they'll let you try them completely risk free for 30 nights,
jerk off on him.
Fuck on him,
sleep on them,
drool on them.
We don't give a shit.
Uh,
it gets even better if you order right now,
they'll give you 50% off a set of sheets plus free shipping.
Just go to boll and branch.com.
That's B o l l and branch.com and use the Promo Code [inaudible] that's,
that's right.
Okay.
She just said,
is that right?
That is right.
Get $50 off,
uh,
off a sheet set immediately by going to be o,
L L and B r a n c h.com.
And using the Promo Code [inaudible].
All right,
mercifully,
here's the last one.
Legal Zoom number one,
uno,
uh,
reliability.
More than a million people have already trusted legal zoom to start their
business and corporations,
LLCs,
nonprofits,
DBEs,
and more using legal zoom to get started the right way.
Number two de dos experience.
You can account on legal zoom experience.
You can count on a legal zoom oh experience period.
You can count on legal zoom for all the details.
They've been helping all types of business owners for 15 years.
Number three,
helpful support.
They have the right people standing by ready to help you with your questions.
All based in the U S number four of Jesus Christ.
Legal advice.
Legal Zoom is in a law firm so they built a network of independent attorneys in
48 states.
You'll get answers to your legal questions and they can review supplier contract
contracts,
employment laws and help with most of the day to day situations that pop up
there.
This is how you know these guys are on point is because they need to be on point
and you need people who can't even write fucking exciting copy.
This copy is so fucking dry.
You know that these guys going to dot all the i's and cross all the t's,
even the ladies,
even the ladies.
You know what I mean?
I don't mean just when I say guys,
I mean everybody.
Yeah,
well that's a sexist term.
Well,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
And finally,
number five,
no surprise here.
Legal Zone,
no surprises.
Sorry.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency with upfront pricing and customer
views with a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Uh,
make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter birth to checkout to save even more.
That's legal zoom.com are right and it's over.
It's over.
All right.
You guys want some drum notes?
Shit.
Before I get off the podcast,
why did,
down here,
you guys know that song by sting love is stronger than justice.
A lot of people sleep on stink,
you know,
cause he comes out all yoga it up,
still looking like he could bang a 22 year old and every he's like,
ah man,
that's fucking a baby boomer elevator music.
Uh,
well I like it.
I like it.
Um,
is a song on a,
what does that 10 summers tails is a song.
Love is stronger than justice.
It's just some drum nerd shit.
Now I've listened to that song at least a thousand fucking times and I thought
it was like,
I don't know if it's bar a measure.
I don't know to say it.
I thought you counted seven twice then you counted four,
four,
then three,
four and then seven.
Right.
She can I actually play this here.
Why don't I play the fucking song?
I'll show you.
So this is some fucking,
this is the dumbest Shit I think I'm going to do.
Oh,
that's right.
I can't play it on my fucking laptop for whatever fucking reason.
Um,
yeah.
Cause I have too many things signed into fucking iTunes and then my old shit,
I can't,
I don't remember the password for.
Okay.
I thought the big brother was looking at me through the camera.
Can't they fucking see?
Can't they see that?
Is that it's made,
let me see if I can fucking play this for you.
Okay.
All right.
So I always thought that this is how you counted it,
right?
Three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
one
right?
It finally dawned on me today that when I was counting four,
four and then three four,
four plus three is seven.
She can count the whole fucking thing and she's seven
that ain't the one.
Here we go.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
four,
three,
five,
six,
seven one.
So it's really for fucking measures is seven and I was like,
oh,
the plane who fucking seven twice.
Then they go for,
for dentistry for days back to seven.
It's like no stupid.
They're just making it sound like it's in four,
four and then all of a sudden they lop off one beat and you're like,
oh,
what the fuck?
But back to one again,
which really is the layman's term for still being at seven.
I learned that while walking at pit bull picking up dog shit this morning.
Ah,
what the fuck are you been doing?
So anyways,
um,
how the fuck do I get out of this?
You know,
the defense in me,
as much as I also loved that album,
that fucking out of all the new shit that I listened to,
uh,
you know,
as I watched the Grammy's and I was like,
I am downloading everything that wings some Grammy's here,
right?
Not Everything,
but you know,
so I basically,
I downloaded a,
I can't remember Alabama shakes the weekend.
Okay.
Leonardo Dicaprio.
It's a fuck set guys.
That rapper who won everything,
I can never remember Kendrick Lamar,
right?
I downloaded all,
all his shit that,
and I like all of this stuff I got to tell you like,
uh,
the one that actually I liked the best is the weekend.
I just think it's a fucking,
it's an unbelievable album.
Unbelievable.
Guys get 'em amazing
voice and some of the songs,
he really does sound a lot like Michael Jackson,
but not in,
not even in a bad way,
just like influenced by the guy.
Um,
so this morning when I walked,
when I was walking around the block,
I listened to rat round and round starting the day off with the little Bobby
blue.
Right?
Did I listen to that?
Sting song and I was thinking like,
ah,
that's what I figured out.
Wait a minute.
Four,
three is seven and what the fuck?
Literally picking up dog shit with a big goofy grin on my face and this fucking
beautiful woman jog by looking at me like it was just got excited about dog
shit.
See listening to a podcast about dog shit.
Just one of those moments,
you know,
he's just like,
yeah,
whatever,
you know.
Anyways.
And then I was just like,
all right,
I keep,
as much as I keep trying to listen to new music,
I keep going back to the shit I listened to when I was growing up.
So,
um,
out of all the ones that I keep coming back to that guy's fucking album,
I just think it's the shit.
So I'm not,
I'm not 100% over the hill,
you know what I mean?
And I actually have,
unbeknownst to me,
I have a college gig coming up,
which I'm very excited,
but I rarely do college gigs anymore.
I don't know why,
you know,
I have to keep doing college kids cause I gotta keep my fan base being,
I've got to keep getting the next generation of people.
That's how it works.
You know,
you can't,
you don't want to grow old with your crowd and they're just reminding you how
old you are.
It's like I should only think that,
you know,
twice a day when I'm brushing my teeth,
put the toothpaste on.
You start brushing,
you look up what a foe.
Oh,
it's me.
You know,
I only want to feel that twice,
fill it twice
in a day.
Um,
but uh,
okay.
What happens is,
is if you just kind of state,
you know,
with your fan base,
they get married,
they have kids and even if they want to come out this so fucking tired,
they just want to sleep if they actually get a moment,
you know what I mean?
So,
uh,
you got to keep the young kids coming out.
The young kids,
they can't feel their face,
but they love it.
Um,
oh Jesus.
All right.
That's the,
uh,
the just checking in for you on your podcast.
I will talk to you guys on Monday.
I hope you have a great weekend.
You're constant.
Please enjoy this music and we will say what music?
It is a on the Twitter,
the MMA at the MMP Twitter accounts and um,
okay.
Yeah.
And a whatever.
And then you guys can all right.
[inaudible] play this.
Yeah.
Well I have your own fucking podcast yet.
Fucking car,
right?
See Ya.
Aye.
Depressed dude.
Hey Billy conn exclamation point.
I'd been listening.
I've been listening to your podcast for years.
You're deranged.
Psychopathic perspective reminds me I'm not the only one
shaken ladders.
I don't know what that means is this guy from Boston.
I've been listening to the podcast fie years.
You drained psychopathic perspective reminds me you're not the only one.
Shake and lad his kid.
That still is a song.
Even if the accident,
shaken ladders,
I don't know what that means.
Anyways,
I got a problem.
Yeah,
I was in Boston all last week.
So the fast buck,
the Boston accent kind of came back to the old,
you know,
I got a problem,
get a job,
get a julep duties and get a job.
And for those of you working on your Boston accents job,
just say like jaw.
Like I'm going to punch you in the jaw.
And then B job,
got to get a fucking job,
you know,
kills me right now is like fucking 200 you right now.
Just muttering to self,
give fucking Julep and you cubicle.
Yeah,
I'm freaking out.
Your coworkers just mumbling,
you know,
fucking job.
You fucking Cock sucker.
Um,
I've got a problem for years now.
I've been trapped in my KFC and wet wipes.
Okay,
that's disgusting.
I used to be a bodybuilder and actor and a comedian with fucking prospects right
in front of me,
but then adulthood raped me in the eyes.
How Jesus could you be more dramatic?
It sounds like that fucking chick from uh,
sex in the city,
uh,
crazy bra broke my hat.
I had,
this is the guy again,
crazy broad,
broke my heart.
I had to cut away old friends and family shutting me out of their smiles.
All right,
dude.
This is like getting creepier with each sentence.
If you don't bring this around in like two sentences,
I'm not going to abandon this.
Had to cut away from old friends and family shutting me out of their smiles.
Dude,
what did you do that your friends and family decided they didn't want to be
around you?
Uh,
anyways,
I don't feel sorry for myself or want any pity.
Uh,
I just,
you're not going to get any so good.
I'm glad you don't.
He goes,
I just want to know how to get out of this.
Never ending routine of demise.
Well,
first of all,
I would stop using those golf,
death,
metal words,
you know,
demise.
What else you got in here?
Adult raped me in the eyes.
These,
he like song lyrics,
you know,
to press dude.
What would be the name of his tractor?
Barker.
I'm sure you're going to wipe wipes,
right?
It sounds like I can't sing like that.
Where do you all like digital keyed up to my eyes and all these fucking kids
getting like wet fucking whiplash.
Um,
I work too much in a jeweler that was supposed to pay for my comedy career when
I don't work.
I uh,
I was supposed to pay for my comedy career when I,
when I don't work,
uh,
I sleep or oh,
when I don't work,
I sleep or watch endless DVDs.
I'm 24 years old.
What the fuck this reads like you 56,
dude,
he goes,
I'm tired all the time from all the hating of the world and my body just won't
listen to this screaming frustration in my soul.
Okay
Dude,
you listen to like you listen to progressive metal.
I'm guessing by the words you use here,
uh,
either that you played dungeons and dragons.
I'm really not helping you to depression by shitting on you through all of this.
Um,
don't worry.
I'm going to give you some sunshine here in the end here.
So I sometimes get a Spock,
a motivation to get back in shape and s and start writing script,
but only lasts for a day or two at the most.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then,
and then the work comes and you have to keep going.
And that's what separates the people in life who fucking work and in make it.
And those who don't,
you know,
everything's fun for a couple of fucking days.
I'm going to get shredded.
I'm going to join a box and Jim,
I'm going to look like I'm going to fight in a title fight and you go down
there,
you skip rope.
I'm going to get abs.
You doing all the fucking shit in two days in,
you know,
after two days you get tired.
All right?
And that's what you need the discipline to get up and go over there.
Even though you don't want to,
you know people who've written Oscar winning scripts.
I bet they don't like fucking doing it on,
on a certain level,
but they keep going.
So I would just tell you to keep fucking going.
Anyways,
let me read the rest of this drum overly dramatic shit.
I've lost all faith in the world.
Have nothing to fight for anymore.
I respect you.
Go Fuck yourself attitude and want and want to know what you did to finally pick
yourself up from your Darfur inflicted depression.
Uh,
sorry.
It's not the funniest emails,
but I could really do with you guys.
I know,
dude,
I'm fucking with you.
I know you're going through some shit.
So I'm,
here we go.
I'm going to help you out here.
Uh,
first thing I would do,
get rid of the KFC in wet wipes.
All right?
If you're already kind of a depressed dude,
if you eat bad food,
that's just going to add,
because I'm just speaking personally.
Once again,
not a licensed guy here in case you throw yourself off the fucking roof.
All right?
Um,
yeah.
Number one,
this is what I do.
Go.
He'd go out and get something healthy to eat,
you know,
drink some water.
Okay.
Get eight hours sleep,
wake up and need something healthy.
Then go to the grocery store when you full and go buy a bunch of healthy shit.
Okay?
Chop up the veggies,
chop up the lead to get a fucking salad already made in this.
You don't have to think about it.
All right?
Cook up some fucking chicken.
Chop that shit up.
Make some chicken salad.
You got that in there to get yourself some fucking lunch breed and get yourself
some real bread from a fucking bakery.
Start with that bullshit.
You start eating right and then just start working out.
You're automatically gonna feel good about yourself and fucking stick with that
as far as that other shit goes.
Dude,
you're 24 years old.
All right.
I started comedy when I was 24 you sound like you've already been doing it and
quit,
so you're ahead of where,
where I was at at your age.
So there's no reason to be depressed.
All right?
Um,
this is how I got beyond my depression was I just started observing it.
I looked at it as a spectator rather than feeling a thought and just accepting
it and then being dragged to the bottom of the fucking ocean with it.
I just started to pay attention.
I just sat there and listened to what my brain was telling me and it was a bunch
of negative,
oh my God,
I'm going to fail and I have to go back,
move in with my parents and they're going to die.
I'm going to be able to afford to pay for the house and then I'm going to be
homeless and then I'm just going to die.
And uh,
you know,
nothing's ever going to work out for me.
You know those with the thoughts I was having.
So I just sat back and observed him and I just started going,
I don't want to think that.
I want to think that.
And I would just,
as I felt him coming,
I would just replace it with like a positive thought.
I know this is really corny and simple,
but I kind of started doing that.
And the more I did that because it didn't quite work as to what actually did
work in the beginning at all.
But like I just kept doing it more and more and then I just became conscious of
when my brain was going in that direction.
And I'm working out,
helps me eating right.
Helps me going down to a comedy club,
telling jokes helps me out playing drums,
wrestling with my dog,
you know,
taking me out to dinner.
Just go do something.
Like it's just a choice,
you know,
July 30th so I'm going to happen once.
So am I going to fucking be a miserable cunts on this?
Or I said July 30th,
2012 is only gonna happen unless it's just,
it's just a fucking choice dude.
So,
you know,
if what you're dealing with his clinical,
then it's obviously way beyond me.
So I don't need,
you know,
and then I'll like to fucking apologize.
Like Fred Willard,
um,
I'm sorry that you didn't go to a psychiatrist and you went to a hacky comedian
instead.
Evidently that's my fault
because,
um,
all right,
why don't we end with this segment?
I'm sure I can do another 10 minutes on this to give you at least 45 minutes for
the week.
Let's end with this.
This segment,
oh Jesus,
which is really taking on a life of its own.
I thought it was going to die,
but it is somehow risen.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
And get ready for bill is the dumbest person on the planet.
All right?
Feel for what it's worth.
I think you're fucking crazy and irresponsible explanation point.
I can ever say the x,
x skull exclaim exclamation.
There we go.
Exclamation point.
That's one of the,
you know,
those,
those words that you kind of know how to say,
but you just sort of fly through them.
[inaudible] uh,
what kind of person talks about God like that?
And I love this shit.
This is what they all do.
You should.
And I believe deep down inside you are,
be ashamed of yourself.
Dude.
This is what I love about these fucking maniacs is they're so wrapped up into
what they believe that they listened to.
How much this person just keeps fucking including other invisible people and
then superimposing what he believes in to what you know.
He thinks.
I truly believe because he's so wrapped up in his own fucking world that he
can't possibly even fathom that somebody has a difference of opinion on this
subject.
So he goes,
uh,
you should,
and I believe deep down inside you are,
be ashamed of yourself.
Dude.
Are Your mom and dad's still alive?
What exactly does that have to do with any,
your shtick with respect to God is hurtful,
offensive,
and despicable.
Um,
in three things,
it always has to be three things.
It can't be hurtful and despicable or offensive and hurtful.
It has to be hurtful,
offensive,
and despicable.
Just like comedy has to come in threes.
Um,
how difficult it must be to spew hatred and vulgarities for shock.
Value.
Laughs,
no talent in that my friend.
That's the classic place that people go.
Um,
whenever you,
this is the classic guy where everything is funny until it comes around to the
subject that they take seriously,
100%.
And no one can even joke it,
joke about it or even question it on any level and then they always say that
you're just doing it for shock because they find it shocking.
It's like really my views on women,
women haven't been,
you know,
that didn't offend you.
All the shit that I've said over the two fucking years and none of that is
offended you and now all of a sudden this does anyway,
so he goes,
enjoy your success,
air quotes and all the money you were making on the backs of hard working decent
people that understand what it means to follow the rules and be the best they
can be without putting other people and god down.
The rest of us are watching and we are not laughing.
Dude,
how many people are in your bedroom as your,
do you have a group podcast listening party every week?
All right,
let's get back to that.
Oh,
evidently I am making money on the backs of hard working decent people.
So let me get this straight because I'm standing on a stage.
Evidently what I'm doing is not hard work.
And if people are sitting in the audience automatically,
they're all decent,
hardworking people.
And not only that,
I'm making money on the backs of them,
really do I have some sort of comedy sweatshop,
you know,
comedy factory was sweatshop Labor.
What I do is actually takes advantage of no one.
I stand on a stage and I,
I tell jokes and if you like what I say,
you,
you sit and listen.
And if you don't,
you'll walk out
right where,
where,
you know,
and I love how just because you're in the crowd,
that means you're a decent human being.
Do you know the,
the amount of fucking freaks and scumbags that come up to me,
and this is what I found at a comedy show for the most part,
decent people.
They leave after the show.
I didn't want to bug them.
And then they walk out and then mania come up to me,
you know,
let us do some Jaeger and they fucking spitting in your face and shit,
believe me.
All right.
But I know I made fun of God.
So now,
uh,
you know,
now all of a sudden I'm now all of a sudden you want to talk about people
making,
making money off of decent,
hardworking people.
Take a look at fucking organized religion.
All right?
Those guys don't make those guys live in pretty good.
Scaring the fucking shit out of you.
Every God damn week.
All right.
And I'm entitled to an opinion and I never was cramming,
in my opinion,
down your throat.
I wasn't okay.
You believe in what you believe in and I 100% respect that,
but I have the right to question it.
You know,
and you shouldn't find it shocking that I questioned it.
You should do,
shouldn't you just be what Jesus would do when Jesus just start praying for me.
Anyways,
let's,
let's continue this just in case you're interested.
I was raised Catholic,
married and raised my children Catholic and definitely have my doubts about the
whole organized religion thing.
Great.
So you agree with me?
Not even sure that I believe in God.
Once again,
there's another appoint that we,
that we agree on.
I lost my father three years ago and never would have uttered these words in his
presence.
Neither would I.
What am I voice go up so they know what dude,
I did it on a podcast.
All right,
I'm sorry your father passed away,
but you know that has nothing to do with me.
Do you understand what you're doing here?
Now all of a sudden you're making it seem like I'm walking in with my Mr
microphone into the intensive care saying,
there's no god,
you know,
whispering into somebody's ear in a coma.
He just go into the ground.
We're all like,
dear,
I'm not doing that.
I'm doing a podcast and I'm fucking around.
All right.
If you want to take it seriously,
that's your problem.
Okay,
and if you want to bring up your father passing away as some way to try to guilt
me in to feeling like,
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
In a hateful,
hurtful,
fucking way.
Dude,
those are all your issues.
They have nothing to do with me.
All right,
send.
He goes on to say that his dad believed that there was something out there
responsible for all the beauty in the world,
uh,
in our world and for our lives as human beings.
I don't even disagree with that.
I just know human beings have no idea what it is until they fucking die.
So I'm not gonna sit there and listen to another human being who tries to scare
the shit out of me and who living in a fucking palace telling me that if I
become rich,
I'm not going to heaven.
I'm not out of my mind to think that that reeks of a fucking scam.
The same way late at night when they have those fucking gold coins that
evidently are with 50 bucks and they're selling them for 1999 that that doesn't
recover.
Scam.
Somebody actually sent me a,
a,
an email.
Of course I didn't save it.
Evidently get sprayed with like a dollar,
something worth of gold.
Okay,
so they're making,
what is that?
A 2000% profit.
All right.
Believe it or not,
just because you're walking around and talking about religion and the afterlife
and and doing unto others and you're talking this great game,
it doesn't mean that you can't be full of shit.
All right?
Okay.
And I'm not saying that I'm right about what I feel,
but this is just it.
It reeks of,
of,
of a scam.
I really believe that there is some sort of thing out there and I wouldn't be
surprised if there is something after this.
I wouldn't be surprised if you just go into the ground and you decay and you
give life to the next fucking thing.
I wouldn't be surprised if earth is punishment for something that I did in,
in a different solar system.
That's another thing about religion and forget about the dinosaurs is it doesn't
even bring up space.
Okay.
Let's say there is this all powerful big being.
And I'm just trying to question this right now,
so I'm not trying to be shocking or I'm just questioning this.
Let's say there is this all powerful being being that created the everything
that there is.
Okay?
The entire solar system.
Why would you do all of that and just put people on this one planet that's like,
you created an,
an uh,
uh,
you built this house that has
an infinity basically amount of rooms,
bedrooms,
and you just put everybody,
you're only using one room in the house.
It doesn't make any fucking sense whatsoever.
And that's one thing about Scientology for as much shit as people give
Scientology,
at least it has the brains to incorporate outer space,
you know?
I don't know if that's a really good point,
if that's really fucking stupid,
but you know,
I don't fucking know.
So anyways,
yeah,
dude,
I wasn't trying to offend you or anything that you fucking,
I was just trying to be funny and I'm just fucking around and if you want to
take this shit seriously,
that,
that is totally your fucking choice.
Um,
you know,
that's it.
All right.
I'm fucking done with that.
All right,
let's move on to the next person trashing me.
Um,
oh,
what the fuck?
Okay.
Where the fuck is it?
Jesus Christ.
I think I only buy,
we put one of my thought,
I had another one.
I'm really just organize this week.
That's because you don't have Jesus in your life.
You don't want to have Jason.
Another guy said,
I love how you pick on a,
on a,
uh,
a punching bag of religion,
basically saying like,
it's very easy to make fun of Christians,
but I don't dare make fun of Muslims because if you make fun of them,
Oh Shit,
look what's going to happen.
You know?
And which I thought was fucking hilarious because the person was sitting there
talking about how insensitive I am.
And then it basically,
in a round about way,
we're alluding to the fact that people who are Muslim means that you're a,
you're a fucking,
uh,
you know,
you're going to blow up.
Like they're all going to blow up planes and that type of shit.
You know,
I went to a wedding one time,
this girl was Pakistanian.
They actually address that,
that what they fucking hate it was at all.
You know,
Christians thought that all of them just wanted to walk around blowing up shit.
And,
uh,
and I also,
it was funny that this guy's fucking sitting there suggesting that,
uh,
people just because they're Christian,
that they're peaceful.
When do you know,
what is it?
Once every 18 months,
some Jesus freaks fucking kills an doctor.
That's pretty much par for the course,
isn't it?
Um,
no,
and it's,
it,
it's not safe to make fun of Jesus freaks.
It really isn't.
It really fucking isn't.
And I think Bill Maher is out of his fucking mind to say what he says in like,
or actually has balls the size of the Grand Canyon to say what the fuck he says,
and then just walk out in Wade into those people and just like,
I would never do that shit anyways.
And I got to admit the level with which that people take this shit seriously.
It actually kind of creeps me out to eat,
to continue talking about this shit.
So,
uh,
this might be the last fucking week of it because I've definitely made my
fucking points.
And at this point we're just going to go around in circles and I'm just going to
piss people off.
So,
uh,
let's move on to this last guy.
What?
She brought up some great points.
Um,
all right,
set a bunch of Nice stuff.
And then he said,
all right,
enough with the Dick Sucking.
I was going to,
I was going to criticize religion,
but to describe those belief is,
is to mock them that,
and you know what dude?
That's what I learned.
Um,
yeah.
If you describe them,
then you start making fun of them and then everybody gets mad.
Or as you're saying,
they're just so ridiculous.
You just have to,
you know.
Anyways,
let's fly ahead here.
Yeah.
He said,
you mentioned needing a code in the absence of religion to live by.
Um,
I'm not sure how much,
um,
of the,
I don't read thing as a Shtick,
but I recommend an excellent text used in an intro to Undergrad and Undergrad
ethics course called the elements of moral philosophy by James.
I don't know if that's rock Kells or Rachael's.
Um,
everybody goes on and on about Jesus.
But Socrates who define morality is how we ought to live.
Let it compelling life.
As you probably know.
Actually,
I don't,
I just know him as a party reference.
Um,
what do you fucking Socrates,
you know,
that's one of those references that even more ons can use and get away with.
And I'm sad to say I'm one of those people.
Um,
he said,
I didn't know the shit he was found guilty of corrupting the youth.
He thought Zeus,
Venus areas,
et Cetera,
smacked of bullshit.
All right?
Think about that.
Right?
They're corrupting the youth.
Now I Christians,
Muslims and everybody today would say that.
Yeah,
that is bullshit.
That those people do not exist because now we've evolved to,
there's only one God.
There's only one bank.
There's one world power.
Um,
and let's see.
And as punishment,
he was forced to take his own life by drinking hemlock poison.
Once again,
another death because of organized religion.
You know,
these Jesus freaks,
these,
these people who were into fucking,
I even got one.
The reason why I don't make fun of,
uh,
the Muslim religion has really,
because I don't know anything about it.
And the reason why I make fun of Christianity is because that's what I was
brought up.
And those are the stories that,
that I,
that I hear and all I know about Muslims is basically,
uh,
you know,
the couple of wars with Iraq.
So I basically don't know shit.
I just think what you,
you've wrapped your wrap your women up and bounty paper towels and then cut the
clips off.
Am I wrong?
Am I wrong on that one?
If they're not allowed to show their fucking songs because,
uh,
you're going to get an erection and because you were that bed sheet,
everybody's going to fucking see it.
I don't really think about it,
but I would definitely make fun of it if I knew something about it,
but I don't.
All right.
And I reserve the right to make fun of the fucker religion that I was brought
up.
And,
um,
so anyways,
he says I'm,
Socrates was a humble man,
famously announcing all I know is my ignorance.
Um,
he sought one.
I love people who would take that at face value.
He shut.
He was your fucking moron right there.
Right there.
You know,
Jesus is the solution.
He sought answers to questions,
whereas religion prohibits questioning answers.
Yeah,
a fucking brilliant.
This guy is really smart.
You should do a podcast instead of me.
I'm a fucking idiot.
Listened to that.
He sought answers to questions,
whereas religion prohibits questioning answers.
And if anything fucking proves that it's the 50 emails I got this week.
Ah,
I like how I'm actually asking like,
I'm questioning religion on any sort of intelligent level.
Um,
I think actually,
I think I am just because I say cut and fuck doesn't mean I'm not,
uh,
bringing up some good questions.
All right.
Let's finish this for,
uh,
for Socrates.
The unexamined life is not worth living.
Okay.
Um,
his sentiments on marriage and nagging women are remarkably,
remarkably similar to your own,
so underrated.
Socrates,
overrated.
Jesus.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
you know,
that's dead.
That is the one thing,
and I'm not being a dick here,
that I don't understand about people who like I respect people who who you know
are raised in religion or,
or find a religion that speaks to them and that they decided to commit their
lives to what?
And what I don't understand is,
you know,
and it brings you this piece,
right?
Am I wrong there?
All right,
so it brings you this piece,
but then if anybody questions,
okay.
That belief that you have,
how quickly it turns violent,
like the amount of people who died because they question these a holy people is
you don't find that fucking like hilarious and ridiculous on any level.
Like they're sitting there calling the other person the devil because they're
questioning their beliefs and they're saying that that other person is going to
hell and then they turn around and kill the person because they don't believe in
the holy pure way that they live their life.
I mean,
I just,
I can't get behind that.
Okay.
I can't get behind that the same way.
Is it the same way?
It's just because you're a red sox fan,
you can't recognize the talent of Derek Jeter and I gotta be do full cubies you
fig.
Now he's the shit.
I don't know.
I don't want to fucking know why.
Why do I continue with this shit?
Um,
I dunno.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
And once again,
I'm not disrespecting your religions.
Okay?
But this is my podcast and when I bring shit up,
I fucking go off on it.
And I,
and I definitely go over the top saying that somebody was pet play in the
upright bass with Jesus is juggler is fucking hilarious because it's over the
top.
And I believe the God in my world thinks it's funny.
Okay.
He's God.
Why would he be intimidated?
I,
there's another thing too.
I don't understand why God would make all this stuff.
Okay.
And then just be so doe angry all the time.
Jesus Christ here.
I gone back in it again.
I got a lot of questions.
Fuck you.
It's by podcast.
I know.
That's why I don't understand.
Okay.
You know,
I,
it's,
it's more like,
you know,
when you,
when you build a bookshelf and yet you're just standing back a Meijer and your
work and then it falls down on the floor and you're like God damn fucking piece
of Shit and you start blaming the bookshelf even though you made it,
you're the one who put it up there.
You know,
I guess technically.
Dot.
God didn't make a,
he didn't make titty bars.
I guess those are man made,
but uh,
you know the broad cinema ma or
wow.
I'm really fucking,
I was just going to say,
made in his image.
Isn't that,
isn't that what you guys say?
They found a dabble.
Dabble.
They got the devil in him.
Um,
all right.
What have,
all I'm saying is because it really got serious this week,
people,
people really get fucking,
they took it a little too seriously.
All right,
so back the fuck off.
Stop taking it so God damn seriously.
And you know,
why don't you actually practice what your preacher preaches and why don't you go
pray for me?
Why don't you do that instead of coming on here telling me,
you know,
you've given me your wrath.
Isn't that one of the seven deadly sins?
You fucking maniacs.
You just as fucked up as I am and you don't know shit either.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
God bless all of you.
Okay.
I hope you find what works for you and a seriously,
if I'm bugging you,
don't listen to the podcast.
God knows I'm not making any money off it.
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
that's it.
You guys all have a great weekend.
A,
I tell you where I was going to be this week,
but I'm worried some Jesus freak is going to show up.
So,
uh,
that's it.
That's it.
Have a great week and I'll talk to you next Monday.
Hopefully
some.